die Energiefrage schauen wir uns erstmal
ganz genau an in Deutschland die
Regierung sind weiter auf erneuerbare
Energie und gleichzeitig aber die
Kohlekraftwerke die laufen und laufen
und laufen Sie Herr mai sie sagen wenn
wir so weitermachen dann wird es vor
allem auch mit der Wirtschaft
Bergabgehen ihr Thema ja also er Scholz
ist ja gerade zurückgekehrt aus
Südamerika und hat dort mit in
Argentinien in Brasilien und in Chile
verhandelt
es ging natürlich um die Wiederbelebung
des Freihandelsabkommens aber vor allen
Dingen ging es um die Sicherung von
Rohstoffen die man auch braucht für den
Umbau der deutschen Wirtschaften nämlich
Rohstoffe wie Kupfer Lithium und dem
berühmten Wasserstoff er hatte nur
obwohl Robert habe ich ein großer Freund
vom grünen wasserstoff ist er hatte
Robert habe ich nicht mitgenommen und
das hatte vielleicht auch einen Grund
gehabt weil nämlich Robert habe hier in
Deutschland gerade sehr viel zu tun hat
wir laufen nämlich in eine große
eventuell Katastrophe gerade in Berlin
gerade in Ostdeutschland denn
wenn die Raffinerien in Schwedt und in
Leuna keine Treibstoffe produzieren dann
wird in Ostdeutschland kein Auto fahren
kein LKW fahren kein Flugzeug in vom ber
abheben und das Problem in der ganzen
Geschichte ist das dass man gesagt hat
wir wollen kein russisches Erdöl mehr
haben aber man hat nicht vorgesorgt
dafür was das was ist dann geht wie man
denn diese Lücke füllen kann und
interessanterweise stellt man sich das
jetzt gerade so vor im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium also ein
bisschen schwer kommt so ein bisschen Öl
aus Rostock an und irgendwann vielleicht
ein bisschen aus Danzig und irgendwann
vielleicht im März dann etwas aus
Kasachstan übrigens dann kommt wieder
Erdöl aus der brustspanner aus der
Pipeline wir bezahlen dann nur durch
Leitungskosten an Russland aber da hat
Herr Kellner auch gesagt das ist gar
nicht so schlimm das bezahlen die Sachen
für uns das vielleicht dann das Geld
dann oben drauf geschlagen wird der
durchleitungskosten das entweder nicht
gewusst oder nicht gesehen mit anderen
Worten schaut man sich die Energie
Situation an schaut man sich die
Situation an laufen wir in ein großes
Problem hinein denn um nur eine Zahl zu
nennen wenn man sich wirklich auf Polen
verlässt auf den Hafen in Danzig dann
kann dann sich 36 Millionen Tonnen im
Jahr umsetzen
und 30 Millionen Tonnen braucht allein
Polen dann blieben noch 6 Millionen
Tonnen übrig und sowohl
Vollauslastung Schwedt voll Auslastung
Neuner sind jedes Mal 12 Millionen
Tonnen das heißt 24 Millionen Tonnen wir
haben also ein riesiges Loch was die
Versorgung von Erdöl betrifft und das
hat was zu tun mit der Utopie von
robertal der glaubt das ist alles nicht
so wichtig wir brauchen das eigentlich
alles nicht mehr wir wollen Elektrik wir
wollen alles umstellen auf E-Mobilität
wir wollen unbedingt das hinbekommen
dass wir nur noch Wasserstoff haben wenn
mal die Sonne nicht scheint der Wind
nicht weht und deswegen interessiert
mich das alles gar nicht und was mich an
Schwedt interessiert denke ich gesagt
habe ist eigentlich nur dass wir dort
auch ein zusätzlichen Standpunkt haben
für unsere neuere wasserstoffindustrie
zu machen und auch um ihre These jetzt
nicht nur in im Osten Deutschlands zu
lassen sondern mal auf unser gesamtes
Land zu beziehen sie glauben also in der
Energiepolitik darin wie derzeit eine
Sackgasse rein ja das denke ich schon
weil warum haben wir gehabt was ist der
ganze Kern des Streit zum Rad es ist was
ganz einfaches und zwar sagt man erstens
wir wollen ähm wir wollen die
erneuerbaren Energien ausbauen dazu
brauchen wir als Backup gastkraftwerke
die wollen wir nicht mehr mit Erdgas ähm
bedienen sondern mit Wasserstoff
deswegen brauchen wir eine Infrastruktur
für Wasserstoff Gaskraftwerke Netz etc
pp bis zum Jahr 2030 wollen wir das
geschafft haben dann bis dahin haben wir
eine Lücke das soll jetzt
durch die Kohle
gefüllt werden denn wir haben ja zu
wenig Erdgas also muss müssen es die die
muss es die Kohle Verstromung sein
Kernkraft wollen wir nicht warum wollen
wir keine Kraft das ist auch ziemlich
einfach denn Kernkraft ist wie
Wasserstoff eine Zukunftstechnologie und
es könnte sich ja vielleicht
herausstellen dass sie Kernkraft die
wesentlich zukunftsfähigere Technologie
ist und dann will man sich auch keine
Konkurrenz in dieser Geschichte machen
heißt mit anderen Worten Nutzfahrzeug
muss weggebaggert werden damit bis 2030
die Energie Lücke gedeckt wird weil man
glaubt 2030 ist man dann immer in der
Utopie das
wasserstoffschnaufen Hören neben mir und
bin mir sicher Peter du möchtest bei
diesem Thema einiges ergänzen total
verrückt ist ich Verteidigung Robert
habe glaube mir kein Mensch also Robert
habe kann für die Abhängigkeit aus
Deutschland von russischen Öl und von
russischen Gas überhaupt nichts das ist
gegen die Grünen passiert das ist halt
passiert von ostdeutschen Politikern die
sehenden Auges 30 Jahre lang eine pro
russische und auch eine damit Politik
gemacht hat die haben sich teilweise
kaufen lassen ihre Landesverbände lebten
davon dass sie von Russland unterstützt
worden sind das war ein Manfred Stolpe
das waren Matthias Platzek das waren
Herr Sellering und das waren Frau
Schwesig und das war Herr Kretschmer
unten in in Dresden wir können die ganze
Pipeline die ganze Nord Stream Pipeline
wie sie dann durch Deutschland
durchläuft durchgehen und die gesamte
Strecke war gekauft und die war voll mit
kremlobbyisten und das geht bis nach
niedersachsenrand dafür kann Robert habe
nichts das heute noch Öl in da ankommt
trotz eines Embargos das liegt an Robert
habe Weg der hat dafür gekämpft das kann
man ihm nicht angreifen man kann ihn
ganz ganz viel man kann ihn eine völlig
krude Windkraft Politik an Ankleiden man
kann ihm eine völlig ein völlig cooles
Verhältnis und fast schon ein ein
heiliges Verhältnis gegen die Kernkraft
an angreifen man kann ihm angreifen
dass ihr jetzt das ganze Land zu
Spargeln will ohne dass noch
irgendjemand irgendwo eine
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung machen
will ohne dass die Bürger noch beteiligt
werden das kann man ihm alles angreifen
man kann ihn nicht angreifen dass
lützerath abgebaggert wird ist ein Kohle
Kompromiss statt fünf Dörfern wird nur
noch eins abgebaggert und statt und der
gesamte Kohleausstieg ist auch dann
Robert habe fällt mir so schwer wie mir
das Feld 10 Jahre vorgezogen dafür fällt
nur Lutz und vier Dörfer fallen da da
finde ich aber das Schwedt wir müssen
jetzt leider mal auch unsere Zuschauer
in den alten Bundesländern mit ein
bisschen Ostdeutschland Nerven Schwedt
ist zu über 80% im Besitz eines
russischen Staatskonzerns und das ist
erst passiert mit der großen Erhöhung
der Anteile kurz vor dem Ukraine kriegt
kurz vor dem Überfall da haben Länder
wie wie Brandenburg und Minister die
nicht grün waren zugelassen dass sich
die Russen da hat noch weiter einkaufen
konnte dass ein Vladimir Putin mit
seiner kriminellen Kamera da noch
richtig richtig irgendwie merken konnte
90% unseres Benzins in Berlin und in
Umgebung kommt aus kommt aus Russland
das ist russendiesel den wir jedes mal
tanken und ich möchte da das nicht und
wenn es auf 15 teurer ist und Robert
Habeck hat das in dem Fall wirklich
nicht zu verantworten
sie haben eine große Wanne genommen und
alles reingeworfen und jetzt gucken wir
mal was in der Wanne alles liegt erstens
die wir können natürlich gerne Histo
Geschichte betrachten das wird uns jetzt
in der jetzigen Situation nicht helfen
doch dass sie nein es hilft nicht es
hilft nicht weil sie bekommen mit
Geschichtsbetrachtung kein Erdöl Problem
gelöst in diesem Moment sie bekommen
kein Kraftstoff produziert mit
Geschichtsbetrachtung sondern sie müssen
dann damit hier auch noch Fahrzeuge
fahren damit das funktioniert ich weiß
gar nicht wie sich das vorstellen wenn
die ausfallen aber gut dann müssen
Tankfahrzeug kann aus Polen kam
Tankfahrzeug Bundesländern kommen also
das kommt
nein nein nein nein Moment Moment die
haben ausgerechnet wie viel Punkte
brauchen um Leuna
zu versorgen mit Erdöl von und das
funktioniert nicht es funktioniert nicht
es ist irgendwie Tankwagen können sie
gar nicht auf die Straße stellen kaputt
gegangen
vom Kreml pudern einfach kaputt gegangen
ja nein das ist schön ich meine
moralisch ist das wunderbar was sie
sagen und moralisch könnte ich mir auch
die Hände daran wärmen nur trotzdem
davon wird kein Liter Benzin Entstehen
von all dem was sie gerade gesagt dann
wird kein Liter Benzin produziert kommt
kein Liter Benzin an die Tankstelle
stellen und was ich von einer Regierung
erwarte ist nicht auf die Vergangenheit
zu schauen sich nicht ähm vor
Historikern oder nicht Historikern
entstanden Fuß zu machen sondern was ich
erwartet weit schauen zu denken weit
schauen zu denken was mache ich jetzt
mit dieser Situation die ich habe die
gehe ich damit um was habe ich für
Lösungsmöglichkeiten und die
Lösungsmöglichkeiten sind nämlich sehr
schwierig
denn Widerspruch an der Stelle natürlich
könnte man sagen wir beziehen das Erdöl
dann über den Hafen Rostock in dieser
Woche hat das Ministerium das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium ganz klar
gesagt wir bauen keine zweite Pipeline
nach Rostock ich denke einfache Frage
möchten Sie dass wir in der Situation
weiterhin Gas und Öl aus Russland kaufen
ich wäre sehr dafür gewesen zu sagen
lasst uns mal überlegen wie wir damit
umgehen wie schaffen wir Alternativen
was hat denn Frau was hat denn Frau
Werbung gemacht Frau Werbung hat in Riga
gesagt wir wollen nichts mehr haben und
sie wusste nie in diesem Moment
überhaupt nicht wie das gewährleistet
werden kann das ganze wie man überhaupt
eine Idee hat das Land zu versorgen wir
sind ein eine Industrienation wie wollen
Sie das hinbekommen natürlich können Sie
fragen wollen sie das von da haben nein
Sie können dann sagt auch das Kind ja
also dieses Essen will ich nicht das
habt ihr nun davon dass ich verhungere
sie müssen eine realistische Politik
machen realistischer sie sind gerade im
Wahlkampf hier in der Hauptstadt und ich
kann mir vorstellen dass viele
Bürgerinnen und Bürger auch Diskussionen
wie diese verfolgen und sie fragen ja
weiß ich jetzt auch nicht für mich ist
wichtig das ist irgendwie bezahlbar ist
und das ist der Regierung vertrauen kann
dass das in guten Händen ist und man
sich kümmert wird dieses Vertrauen
gerade verspielt spüren Sie das sie sind
jetzt gerade viel auf der Straße
unterwegs
gehört Benzin auf jeden Fall dazu das
ist hier deutlich teurer als in anderen
Regionen und das hat natürlich mit der
Situation in Ostdeutschland zu tun das
hat mit der Infrastruktur zu tun die
einfach mal jetzt nicht in der Art und
Weise bereitgestellt werden kann weil
die Liefersituation sich verändert hat
Punkt die wird sich absehbar aber auch
nicht verbessern wir werden Lösungen
finden müssen die ohne Russland
funktionieren und zwar aus guten Gründen
und aus tiefer innerer Überzeugung
müssen wir das tun die Frage ist wo will
ich dann anschließend hin die Frage ist
ja richtig gestellnummer ist Wasserstoff
dann die Lösung das würde ich gerne
glauben wenn ich gleichzeitig sehe dass
in Berlin eine wasserstoffinfrastruktur
aufgebaut wird das ein echter
Transformationsprozess der auch mit der
Schaffung von neuen Arbeitsplätzen
verbunden ist in Ostdeutschland
stattfindet da sind wir aber in den
Ansätzen da gibt's noch gar keinen Plan
in der Schublade und das übrigens kann
man dann habe ich zum Vorwurf machen das
kann man auch den Grünen zum Vorwurf
machen denn die erzählen dass Märchen ja
schon seit Jahrzehnten den kommt das
jetzt quasi ideologisch gelegen wenn man
so will dass jetzt sozusagen aus Gründen
an der Stelle man über Alternativen viel
stärker nachdenken muss aber man hätte
gerne auch in der Schublade haben können
das heißt hier jetzt an der Realität zu
scheitern zeigt auch das schon vom
Ansatz mehr manche Ideen nicht
ausgereift ist und das ist das was mich
massiv ärgert man hätte in der Tat sehr
viel früher anfangen müssen auch
alternative und das sind wir bei
Pipeline Infrastruktur herstellen zu
müssen damit wir auch andere
Bezugsquellen erschließen können aber
das ist jetzt ehrlicherweise nicht der
Gesprächsstoff auf der Straße die
Menschen wollen dass das Problem gelöst
wird die verstehen ehrlicherweise nicht
warum wir jetzt nur über 49 Euro Ticket
diskutieren und nicht darüber dass auch
für Pendler was getan wird stärker da
erwarten Sie Antworten von der Politik
und ich glaube da sind wir gefordert und
jetzt weniger bei der Frage wollen wir
morgen den Haaren nach Russland wieder
aufdrehen da habe ich jetzt noch keinen
getroffen wenn sie so gesprächig zuhören
glauben sie manchmal verlieren wir uns
zu sehr verliert sich die Politik auch
zu sehr in Fachfragen und beantwortet zu
wenig die Fragen der Menschen
ja auf jeden Fall also ich will jetzt
nicht abstreiten dass das Thema Energie
sehr wichtig ist und dass es viele Leute
ja vielen Leuten Sorgen macht und auch
finanzielle Probleme macht wenn sie
nicht mehr tanken können und so weiter
aber ich sage wir stehen vor
vor anderen existenziellen Problemen die
die Bundesrepublik
bedrohen und das ist eben eines oder
mein Thema eben die Islamisierung die in
Deutschland stattfindet die Gefahr die
vom politischen Islam ausgeht ich sehe
für all diese Fragen sich ehrlich gesagt
auch eine Lösung ja weil ich meine wir
haben kluge Leute im Land wir haben
ja wir haben immer noch auch starke
Behörden und Experten und so weiter die
sich mit diesen Fachfragen
auseinandersetzen und wo man dann auch
ja durch technische Weiterentwicklung
durch die Technologie dann auch Lösungen
findet